my name is joy pullman and i'm a mother
with six kids
and i'm the executive editor at the
federalist
i get up at 5 30 i may have 6 000 words
to edit between 6 and 8 a.m may have 50
emails to answer as well then i head to
the kitchen to see what state it's in
with all my children hanging from the
chandeliers we don't have chandeliers 1
32 o'clock is nap time and then i'm
working
i get a lot from young women you know
how do you do it
i say
try not to if you can help
[Music]
looking at all the college options that
i had why was i going to college in the
first place i was going to college to be
educated to take the talents that i had
and make the most of them
i had a gut feeling that at hillsdale is
where i would get the best education you
know the only thing i wish that would
have been better about my hillsdale
experience was me well you know you're
18 years old and stupid
i was an english major and i knew that
from the beginning and loved to write
what i loved really about reporting in
college was being a conduit for other
people's stories how do you get people
interested how do you make sure it's
organized clearly all of those kind of
bits about the craft after hillsdale i
did huge amounts of on-the-ground
reporting i was one of the earliest
people to even pay any attention to this
thing called common core
it came to me from the grass roots from
a mom she called me one day and said
why aren't there any reporters covering
this thing called common core i think
this was 2012 or 2013. it was before
this became a huge grassroots issue
she was saying you know my local school
district is talking about it and i tried
to go to a public meeting about it and
they wouldn't let me in i was
instantly
on her behalf wondering okay this is
weird this shouldn't happen government
101 the people are allowed to go to
public meetings
i also tried to get into that meeting
they wouldn't talk to me about it or let
me know anything about it i just
published a story about the fact that
none of you know they weren't letting
anyone do that information and i got
deluged with emails from people saying
we heard about this too what is this
thing
i happen to be someone just doing basic
journalism when no other outlets were
doing basic journalism on this thing
that really aimed to completely overhaul
and nationalize american education
because of that i became you know he got
a huge following huge amount of
readership and that turned into a book
then it started getting huge media
attention and became a thing that even
eventually donald trump started talking
about
reporting on common core played into our
decision to start a school
people need to be more and better
educated the education is the formation
of a human soul and the kind of souls
that you have in your country determine
whether it can be self-governing and i
want my children to be self-governing
and i want their neighbors to be
self-governing
so we started redeemer classical school
in 2016. and it was one room school
house
you know then now we're a four-room
schoolhouse my husband is the headmaster
of the school
and i'm the executive editor at the
federalist
when you have a heart commitment to the
things that are good for me it's really
gotten me through a lot i mean
i know doing all the things that i do
has has been basically a battle the
whole time so
you don't have the heart to fight you
know without someone having shown you
what's worth fighting for
and so that's what i really got from my
uh the classes at hillsdale taught me
what to love right rather than fighting
in bitterness
dr seundel was one of my freshman
english professors and then i took him
of course a bunch of other times the
things that he would talk about in class
were just so touching
um that that i would sit in the back of
his class and cry you know as quietly as
i could i think of hillsdale as kind of
like the shining city on a hill it's
this beautiful place that is so unlike
so almost everywhere else that we have
in the world of course you know it's not
a perfect place but it has so many
excellencies all together in one place
and people have worked over centuries
and they sacrificed to make that
possible so you can go there and get
refreshed you can go there and have hope
[Music]
you know our country is in really
dangerous times through my work you see
some of that grave danger in hillsdale
is for me what gives me so often the
courage to get out there and keep taking
swings
right when i graduated i really wish i
could go back and do it all over again